welcome everyone my name is christopher
pauley i am
a research scientist with front range
biosciences on their research and
development team
and today we're going to be talking
about kind of uh terpenes
what they are how they're made and some
of the enzymes that are responsible for
them and what an enzyme is
and so we'll jump right into it i thank
you for all uh for being here today and
i look forward to hopefully teaching you
something
and so we'll move to the next slide here
and we're going to dive right into what
is a terpene and a terpene
is a taste and smell molecule and so
when you smell cannabis most of what
you're smelling is the terpene profile
and so what are those made of if you see
down in the right hand corner here
i have an isoprene unit highlighted that
is a carbon
building block for what a terpene is so
terpenes are
multiple of these isoprene units built
together
and so we classify terpenes based on how
many of these isoprene units they
contain so a mono would be
one isoprene unit and that's a
monoterpene or dye terpenes two
or sesquiz just three or more of these
isoprene units kind of stack together
and so one interesting thing about the
terpenes is that they have bioactivity
in the sense that
they're changing the effect of the
cannabis you smoke
or ingest and that is something that is
really kind of key to understanding what
cannabis is and how it works with your
body and the way it does and so
they're present throughout the plant
kingdom um all the trees herbs
flowers fruits things that you normally
smell and are like wow this has a great
smell to it
that's the terpenes responsible and so a
lot of people talk about the forest
activity of when you walk through a
forest
you get the smell that's the terpenes
that are interacting with your body that
you're
you're able to kind of talk to the
plants in a way or your body's
responding to what the plants are saying
and so within cannabis this is really
the designation between sativa and
indica
and so when we talk about two strains
with very different effects i give jack
career and og kush as an example here
it's the same active ingredient in both
thca
is kind of the main most abundant
compound in there
and that's the same between the most
sedative indica you can
buy in the most energetic sativa and so
what's really guiding that change is the
terpenes and so
i i kind of look at it like your
terpenes are the steering wheel in your
car
and thc is the gas pedal and cbd is the
brake pedal um
and so that that's a good analogy to
understand kind of how you can smoke thc
in two different strains and get
two vastly different effects but that's
not the entire story with cannabis
because of the entourage effect we have
over 500 bioactive chemicals
and those chemicals are going to
interact with your body as well and when
they're all together in your body they
have a
entourage effect or a synergistic or
antagonistic effect
which changes how a given terpene works
with your body
and so if you see down here it's kind of
interesting in this bottom right hand
corner
i have the difference in alpha and beta
pinene which those two are really
interesting one if you ever get a chance
to smell them
you can smell this chemical bond change
here and so the double bond is up here
in beta pining
up at the top and then in alpha pining
it's just within the ring structure and
so when you smell those two they have
vastly different smells and also
different effects within your body
and so that's just what feeling that
double bond change and how it's binding
to your receptors which is
a very interesting thing for some of
these isom isomers of different terpenes
and we'll get into a little more of the
chemical structures on this next one we
talk about how many terpenes are there
and what
they are and so over 20 000 different
terpenes have been identified in plants
within cannabis we know about 150 of
those
and with the genes that make them are
70.
and so what we can tell there is that we
know 70 genes are responsible for around
150 terpenes
but we don't know which gene does what
and so
when we look at kind of trying to figure
that out
the easiest place to start or the best
way to classify cannabis is by chirping
dominance
and so you'll see some of these
structures around the outside of my
slide here
and it's just basically the built up
over and over again in different
ring structures different conformations
and each of those has a unique effect
with your body
and so and a smell to it as well so you
can identify identify these things just
by
grabbing a draw of cannabis and smelling
it and so
some of the most abundant terpenes that
we find in cannabis are listed out there
for you
um that's not all of them and there's
definitely a few more that can
pop up and we're always kind of
discovering new
types of cannabis out there because it's
a really diverse species
and so we're still working to understand
kind of how many different terpenes are
out there
as our chemical methods get better our
genetic messes get better
and what we're finding is that these
terpene synthases can be really
indicative of what the trapping profile
is
and kind of how that breakdown happens
and so there's many different terpenes
synthases and each of them make
multiple products and so that's kind of
an interesting fact
that they'll take in the same kind of
chemical before and turn it into
multiple different chemicals
and we'll get a little more into that on
this next slide of what an enzyme is
and so when we look at an enzyme in
general
it's kind of the central dogma of
biology they call it that a gene is
transcribed into mrna that's translated
into a protein
and so these proteins are just strings
of amino acids that get strung together
and in your cell they fold into these
really weird conformations
that will have a function to them and so
you'll bind a substrate a substrate or a
precursor are the same things it's just
the chemical that goes into the enzyme
to be converted into something else
and then what the enzyme does is lower
that chemical
activation energy needed for the
chemical change to happen
and or it's a catalyst to making this
reaction happen and we can get a kind of
predictable profile out of an enzyme
and so up in the upper left uh
the upper right hand corner here we see
kind of a simplified diagram of what an
enzyme does
and it's a locking key mechanism of the
substrate really fits into this active
site of the enzyme
and it'll bind very strongly to that and
so once it's found you have this enzyme
substrate complex
that will cause the chemical change to
occur
then your product is down to the enzyme
and that product isn't
wanting to bind to the enzyme as much as
the substrate was so it gets
released and the simple simplified way
is you have this one substrate that's
kind of a triangle and a half circle
and then you get two different color
triangles half circles out
that's a really simplified idea of this
if you see right below that that's what
this actually looks like and so it's
these
kind of beta helic or beta plated sheets
and alpha helices
that form together and then you can see
those little blocks floating around have
chemical structures on them and that
would be a substrate
that would be kind of trying to fit into
this protein and once it does it'll bind
to it and then
that chemical conversion happens and
that's when you get your product profile
out
and so when we look into a given tps
gene
um in cannabis it's a pretty complex
story here
and so we know each enzyme doesn't make
only one terpene
but how many does it make and kind of
are there more than one terpene synthase
making the same
product so what we see is
um in this really nice graph put
together in bootha l
2020 they had shown kind of what each
terpene synthase gene does so if you go
across a row for a given
tps gene there you'll see if it makes
one product or something
make up to four or five products and
basically
that's a predictable profile coming off
that gene by itself
when we have two enzymes there that are
both taking up the same precursor
it's going to compete with each other
and so then you'll have
basically a competition going on you'll
know what each enzyme does by itself
but what about when they're competing
for this precursor
and so we really try and kind of do
functional characterization studies
where we look at this competition
seeing kind of how much a given enzyme
wants to bind that substrate or the
affinity it has to bind that substrate
and then we go ahead and um classify
that and try to
assign numerical values that we can rate
these things and say
oh if you have this tps gene you're
going to be able to eat up all of your
gbp and make
beta pinene or trapinoline or whatever
terpene that we would be talking about
at the time
and so we used phylogeny and kind of
gene similarity to figure out which of
these genes cluster together
maybe have a similar function and also
subcellular localization is a big key in
understanding these terpenes synthase
genes
because the the substrates differ in
different
subcellular compartments so depending on
where you are in the cell
you may have fpp or gpp and make a
different terpene given you express the
same gene in both of those locations
and so we'll get into a little bit more
about what the terpene synthase
family in cannabis looks like and one
important thing about this
is having a gene in your genome doesn't
mean you're going to make that terpene
and so we look at expression of these
genes part of that central dogma idea
and we're really looking for kind of
where are these chirping synthases
expressed
how expressed are they um and are they
in a place that's expressed without much
competition or with the competition we
want
and so when you look at this heat map
over on the right side of the
slide here you'll see we have a bunch of
different flower types at the bottom as
well as
a stem a root and a shoot
and so those are just different tissue
types and so you'll see within each
tissue type there's a different set of
tps genes expressed
and that's a really important thing
because each of these are doing a
different thing if you express terpenes
in your stem you're usually trying to
deter a stem boring pest or pests that
live on the stem or climb up the stem
versus in the root you're more signaling
to something underground like micro
horizon
or underground pest that's going to be
living there and so within this idea of
competition
we're having to say are you expressed in
the same tissue
around the same time point of
development um
and kind of consider that within
competition
and then there's also these
environmentally induced ones that we see
in response to a given pest or a
pathogen that you'll express certain
terpenes to fight that off and the
plants are
very sophisticated in this way that they
have developed over millions of years to
fight off these pests and pathogens
and so we're kind of balancing this of
what's the natural expression of these
serpents and faces
versus what's kind of this
environmentally induced expression
and so when you talk about competition
not all these enzymes compete with each
other
you can kind of break them down into
classes of genes so
tps a is a class gps b is a class
and they each make their own type of
product so monoterpenes have their own
class that would be tpsa
i believe and basically each of those
classes take their own precursor
so some of these genes aren't competing
with each other because some are going
after fpp
some are going after gdp and so we see
that and we
it's kind of considering all of that in
this bigger picture of genetics
and when you start to test for these
genes it gets really um
you have to have all these
considerations in place
and so we'll keep moving on here and
kind of where do these terpenes come
from
and so we know about the genes we know
the gene needs to be there
but what makes that precursor for that
gene and so that's something we always
have to look at
we know gpp you need that in your cell
to make monoterpenes or fpp to make
sesquiterpenes
but where does the fpp come from or
where does the gpp come from
and so if you see over on the right hand
side of this graph i have two pathways
there the mep
pathway and the mev pathway those are
where you get the fpp and the gpp from
and so you see at the end there's tps
genes
and each of those uh purple
uh acronyms are going to be an enzyme
each of the black words are going to be
a precursor
and or product so each pyruvate and g3p
are a substrate that make exp as a
product
and then that dxp is a substrate for dxr
gene
that makes map and so that's how you
read these pathways
and you'll realize very quickly that's a
multi-step process
if you knock out one part of this
pathway you're not going to be able to
make it to the rest of it
and so what we try and figure out is
what's going to determine our total
amount of terpenes versus what's going
to determine our total our
our tripping product profile and so the
tps genes are really great at
predicting a profile so if i test for
the tps genes genotype i can tell you
how much of this terpene versus this one
you're going to make but i can't tell
you what the total amount of terpenes is
because that's determined upstream
from the tps genes they have no
influence or say on how much of this
terpenes produced
and so a lot of times people wonder do
terpene production take away from
cannabinoid production because
gpp sounds really familiar in something
that i know is involved in cannabinoid
biosynthesis
and so as we move into there we'll see
that these two pathways
are indeed connected they're using the
same building blocks gpp
specifically and so there's a
relationship between monoterpenes and
cannabinoids
that it's very um
kind of flexible in a way because
depending on
how much this parental transferase wants
to pull gpp
it's competing with the tps genes to
pull gpp
and so you have this kind of competition
going on between two separate pathways
and even though all the tps genes are
competing with each other they also have
another
competitor to them and so that's where
given that you have a
set amount of upstream precursors the
more monoterpenes you have
the less cannabinoids you have and vice
versa the more cannabinoids you have the
less monoterpenes
just because it's pulling from a set
amount of gpp produced by that plant
and so the next kind of question after
we have all this understanding of
how do all these things work together
what are these genes doing
can i genetically test for a terpene
that i'm interested in and guarantee
that i'm going to produce it
and so a lot of people ask that and it's
it should be a simple answer like we can
test for your cbd gene and tell you that
you'll make cbd or not
but with terpenes it's a little more
complicated and so we'll kind of look at
that on the next slide here
and that is where we get into what is
genetic testing for terpenes
and so we're really reading this dna if
you look up in the
left hand corner that's the code we're
trying to read
and what it actually is so when people
talk about ac
t's and g's this is really what they're
talking about is these
chemical structures that have an
interaction with each other
so your a's bind with your keys and your
c's bind with your g's
and we're reading that code as a linear
string so
we read this side of the code if you
started with that pink g
at the bottom there you would say it's a
g t t c
a is the genetic code of this gene that
we're reading
and so first we test for that do we have
that gene in our genome
it's the sequence there that we're
looking for
and once we can say yes we've inherited
this gene as we'd expect
in some of the offspring we've selected
those offspring the next question you
have to ask is is this gene intact
and expressed as mrna so you can have
what's called a frame shift or a
truncation in the gene
and those are basically the way dna is
read in codons
you'll have a stop codon and if that's
in the middle of your gene
you don't make a successful protein
anymore
and so we're really looking for the
entireness of the gene
as well as its expression because that's
controlled by something outside the gene
and so once we can find that it's
expressed as mrna and the strain
and the offspring that we wanted to
inherit this gene
we can then start to look at is it
expressed in the tissue i want
did i inherit this with a different
promoter enhancer region that's changing
where this gene is going after it's
translated and so
then after that you consider is it
competing with anything else what else
does it have to compete with
to actually produce this terpene in the
given subcellular location that it's
expressed
and so now that we kind of can answer
all those questions and figure out okay
we inherited this gene we want
it's intact and expressed in flowers say
because i want to make my flowers smell
better
it's the only gene there fighting for
this precursor that i want so i know i'm
going to get the
gene or the chirping profile that i want
and
then the question is has this variant
then functionally characterized
and so functional characterization is
when you take this gene out of the plant
and you put it in a different organism
and you make it do its
enzyme activity and so we screen its
enzyme activity and
another organism to say can i reproduce
this product profile that the plant
would normally be making
but in a a soul environment that i can
measure
the other end and so a lot of genes have
been functionally characterized a lot
thanks to booth and judas booth and her
group
and some other groups as well that have
done functional characterization
but the fact that you functionally
characterize the gene
doesn't necessarily tell you you can
predict what the alleles are going to do
an allele is just a different version of
that gene
could be one snip different or 10 snips
different
those could change the amino acid
structure and then also change the
protein function
and so that's what we're really trying
to figure out is what alleles do what
can i then test for certain alleles that
i want to do
the activity that i want and as we
sequence new plants and do more of these
screenings we're realizing the number of
alleles just keeps going up
the diversity in cannabis is huge this
tps family in particular
is a very diverse one and it's something
that
we're continually finding what's out
there even and so
a lot of times most people think they
have something you know
really great this amazing plant they've
been working on for years
it's got a terpene profile like nothing
else out there on the market
and so the way to figure out if you
really have something special is to
sequence it and there's a couple
companies offering sequencing as a
service
but just sequencing it and putting on
ncbi then includes your strain and a lot
of scientific studies after
and the ability to have other people
find genes for you
kind of annotate your genome show you
what's different about your plant versus
other plants out there
and you kind of put that stake in the
ground that so this plan existed on this
date which is something
within the ip world is really important
to say i had this this isn't a man-made
creation
or even if it is it's something i
created
a while back versus something that a new
company that just sprung up tomorrow can
claim they have your plant and then say
your you never published anything about
it but publishing that sequence can
really
um push science forward push our
understanding as a community forward
and that's something that we're very
excited about and
we're definitely trying to do it front
range is push the scientific knowledge
forward as a community
and really do something that can help us
make the future of cannabis
and so my last slide here is we're going
to talk about kind of what does this
mean for the future
of cannabis now that we can test for
these genes we're kind of hitting this
genetic revolution of a crop
that most other crops have gone through
as uh dna sequencing has advanced and
rna sequencing
and so where are we heading with this
information now that we have it
and so kind of the the most obvious is
custom terpene profiles that's something
that
people have hypothesized for a while
kind of like a designer cannabis
that say you have this really great
medicinal or agronomic profile of
terpenes
whether it be anti-inflammatory or
anti-anxiety
you're like i wish i could have a cbd
version of this or i wish i could have a
cdc
version of this and that's something
that with this marker set
um plus our understanding of these
terpenes
we're able to really customize that
plant to keep that trooping profile but
customize the cannabinoid profile you
want
or vice versa on whether it be an
agronomic trait we can kind of keep that
specific pest tolerance or resistance
along with
putting in new cannabinoids helping you
make new products from this and also
treating more conditions by being able
to classify the strains that help a
given condition and that's something
that
has really been un under utilized so far
in the
in the medicinal community of marijuana
is that we understand certain strains
help certain conditions but we don't
really understand
why and so understanding these tps genes
gives you a way to
start to classify that strain as
something that here's why this is
medicinally relevant
it's not just the cbd in it or the thc
in it it's all these other compounds
interacting as an entourage
and here's how i can show you what that
profile is
and then some more fun activities that
you can do with it is take your favorite
strange smell and put it in every candy
background
so say you really like the smell of
german poison
but you don't like thc so much so then
you can make a cbd dominant driven
poison
or as new cannabinoids come out that
could be a cbd v dominant german poison
or so on and i mean the cannabinoids
there's over 100 of them identified so
it's a really long game of how many new
products can you make with the same
chirping profile
and so part of what we're doing with
that idea is being able to design
terpene profiles for a given cannabinoid
profile
and so one of our new products in
california to anybody
is living in california you might be
able to find
near you we sell a string called base
layer from our nursery line long speak
agriculture out there
and it's got a complementary terpene
profile to fit the thcv that it contains
and so with thc you can kind of steer it
either way whether you want it to be
energetic or sedative with thcv it's a
little more energetic there's really no
uh steering that one to be a sedative
strain
and so we're we're harnessing that idea
of we know which terpenes are most
dominant in sativa
um classes and just which ones are
present
and how they work with your body so
we're trying to read for a terpene
profile that'll complement our
cannabinoid profile on there and make
that a really great day strain
if you're going out hiking or doing
something outside that would be a great
strain to use for that
just because the chirping profile and
the cannabinoid profile are synergistic
with each other
to ensure that you will not get tired
from the string
and then the final kind of point i want
to make here about what's
the cool idea behind testing our
trooping profiles is that we can
increase the diversity of cannabis
not only can we identify the diversity
that's out there and try and preserve it
because when corn came around to the
genetic revolution they had a base
understanding of this but it wasn't
to our understanding today and so we
know that mono cropping and monoculture
is a bad thing for most crops and so we
can preserve this genetic diversity that
just
has existed for millennia in people's
basements
and now that we get a chance to sequence
it we can say okay we we know this is
specific clusters of genetic information
that
is different than everything else out
there that may help us fight off
future pathogens or pests that affect
cannabis and so by preserving that
genetic diversity we really gain
um the ability to make cannabis kind of
fire proof or
bomb are future proof that as new things
pop
up we're able to adapt to that and this
plant can continue to survive and be a
useful crop for
everybody who grows it and within that
as well
we can also kind of create new terpene
profiles we can see what's out on the
market right now what's doing well
and then also help you figure out hey
this turpin profile hasn't
really been put together yet and
naturally less breed for that
and that's something that we're really
focused on is trying to figure out what
what's the next new terpene profile that
people are going to desire in cannabis
and it's it's a really personal thing
and
everybody has their own preferences i'm
sure everybody knows
but there are some trends that you can
figure out certain terpenes work with
most people like this
and generally the for specific uses
are are going to be something of the
future
and so i'd like to thank you all for
joining me on this talk
and if you have any questions i'll be
hanging around the presentation after to
answer those for you there's my email as
well on this slide if you want to reach
out to me feel free
if you want to learn more about our
catalog and some of the streams we have
to offer and possibly talk to our sales
team
please feel free to get on
frontrangebio.com
we have some great agronomists and
different sales people that
are just really knowledgeable about the
plant but
i appreciate your time today and i look
forward to
speaking with you more in the future